with the increase in the sharing of data
and information online there is a need
to maintain proper routing and efficient
data transmission from sender to the
receiver node
which comes under the scope for today's
topic
hi guys and welcome to yet another
interesting video by simply learn
but before we begin if you love watching
tech videos subscribe to our channel and
hit the bell icon to remember an update
from us
let's take a look at today's agenda
to begin with we will look into what are
switching techniques
why to apply these switching techniques
and in the end we will look into
different types of switching techniques
let's move on with the first heading
that is what are switching techniques
switching techniques are network
techniques responsible for overseeing
the transmission of data over different
communication channels
they are also responsible for choosing
the best route for data transfer
next we will look into why to apply
these switching techniques
using the switching techniques we can
choose the best and the most efficient
route for data transfer in the network
for example
if we want to send some data from node a
to node b we can do so by
moving from node a to a switch then node
d then to node b
but doesn't this seems like too long
this is where the switching techniques
plays its role
using the switching technique we can
choose the smallest and the most
efficient way that is node a switch then
to the node b
next we will look into different types
of switching techniques
switching techniques can be divided into
three primary types
the first is
circuit switching
that requires a predestined path for
data transmission
then we have message switching which
integrates the destination address with
the data for transmission
and in the end we have packet switching
that divides its message into smaller
units known as packets
packet switching can further be divided
into two different types that are
virtual switching and data ground
switching
now let's look into some details
regarding each of the types
on the first node we have circuit
switching
in circuit switching for data
transmission to occur a pre-established
path is required between the sender and
the receiver node
for example
assume that we call someone
then this request is sent over to the
network switches
and the route is to be established for
the signal to pass through
after that system assigns a route for
the signal to pass through then
the receiver receives the call from the
caller side
this is how it works
now let's look into some points to
remember about circuit switching
for circuit switching we require a
dedicated channel established between
the source and the destination node for
the network to pass through
the data transmission can take place
only after the path is established
and the last point to remember is
other than the sender and the
destination node no node can interfere
with the transmission of data to the
established route
let's look at some advantages and
disadvantages of applying circuit
switching in a network
for first one we have advantages
data transmission in circuit switching
is sure to be established due to the
predestined path
circuit switching is preferred for long
and continuous transmission of data due
to the pre-established path route
then let's look into some disadvantages
the time required to establish the
connection is quite long due to the time
required to establish a path
also due to the continuous transmission
of data in circuit switching
more bandwidth is required for
maintaining the connection
let's move on with message switching
in message switching no predestined path
is established between the sender and
the destination node in the message
this technique integrates the
destination address into the data
transmitted and shared over the network
let's look into the setup to better
understand the working of message
switching
for first step the center node
integrates the destination address into
the message
then the whole message is transmitted to
the switching node in the network where
it gets stored for the next transmission
and similarly like the second step this
transmission of data is done over
the whole network
and finally
through the destination address in the
data it reaches the receiver's node
this is how the message switching works
let's take a look at some points to
remember about message switching
in message switching no predestined path
is established
it uses dynamic routing as the message
is transmitted through the communication
channel in real time
the each node in network switching
stores the data
unless it is transferred over to the
next switch node
let's take a look at some advantages and
disadvantages of applying method
switching
to begin with let's take a look at the
advantages
the size of the data that can be
transmitted over method switching is
variable
in message switching the use of
bandwidth is done in an efficient manner
now let's look into some disadvantages
for message switching the nodes that are
known as the switch node is to be
provided with sufficient storage memory
there is a delay in reaching the
destination due to the message technique
that is the message has to stop at each
of the switch node before it is
transferred over to the destination node
now let's look into the last switching
technique that is packet switching
in packet switching the message is
broken into smaller data units known as
packets
these packets are appended with relevant
network details for the transmission
over the network
let's look into the working of packet
switching
we know that in packet switching the
data is broken into smaller units
packets
which each packet is given a sequence
number for identification
these packets are integrated with
required sender and receiver address and
switching method to choose the smallest
route to reach the destination node
these packets are then recombined at the
destination node in the correct sequence
order
now let's look into some points to
remember for packet switching
for packet switching all the data
packets that are provided with unique
number for identification at the
receiver end that is
one two three and four in the previous
example we just used
packet switching chooses the most
shortest path possible for the data to
reach the destination end
in case we have unreached packet or some
unattained packet the whole message from
the sender side is sent again
to the receiver end
now let's look into some details
regarding advantages and disadvantages
of applying packet switching
advantages of using packet switching is
it provides re-routing in case the
network node is busy
it also allows multiple user to access
the same network and no predestined path
is needed
the disadvantage of applying packet
switching is the protocols that are
needed for the working of packet
switching is very complex
there are often cases of loss of data
packets during the transmission in case
of overloading or corruption of data
with this we have understood how our
data is transmitted over different
communication channels and how to choose
the most efficient path to reach the
destination end
with this we have reached the end of the
video if you have any questions
regarding the topic you can ask them in
the comment section
thank you for watching
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here